five four three and marriage and  marriage I've never done a sitcom before  so I don't know but I've watched them  but I think that we'd probably get away  with more on the show then we could on  the other three networks I'm I mean I'm  quite sure of that I want sex so do I  have it I see no reason to drag you into  it  I look back over the reruns and stuff  and it's really it's funny we tend to  laugh at something we see in ourselves  so obviously somebody's relating to the  Bundys and they have been for a long  time  some people go okay I'm not gonna watch  that that's disgusting and I love that I  love when people say that's the most  disgusting show I've ever seen I go good  I'm glad we're doing it right sometimes  my mom will look at the skip and say are  you really gonna do this I think that  anytime you do something different  you're gonna get reactions and not all  of them are good but at least they're  reacting  [Applause]  [Music]  you